anna hills a pediatric airway surgeon
and associate professor at columbia
medical school doctor thank you for
being here to start
could you explain why is it important
for this group to get vaccinated because
i feel like the whole narrative
has been that kids are fine so why is it
still
crucial to get this group of people the
shots
this is something that we really need to
be talking about
now as we're making this push to get
closer to herd immunity um
kids are gonna are gonna make up a more
and more significant part of the
unvaccinated
population as more adults get vaccinated
and they make up 22 percent of the u.s
population
so we will never if we're looking to
achieve herd immunity which is
you know about 80 or maybe even more
um we're thinking now because this new
b117 variant is even more transmissible
we may need more people vaccinated to
get hurt immunity
that large group of pediatric people
is going to make a significant portion
of our population
they really need to get vaccinated
besides all of that though you know i
i've got to be honest with you guys you
know being
an airway surgeon here at this hospital
i just don't want to
have to put another surgical breathing
tube in
another child who is sick with this
disease i don't want to see another sick
kid in my clinic um and
you know we've been talking all along
about the kids how kids are less
affected
but i have to tell you we're seeing kids
get sick and we're seeing them get
really sick
thank you for sharing that doctor so i'm
curious do you think
that getting this group vaccinated is
going to really help us
in that timeline right because again
you know i know i hear you saying that
some kids are still getting sick but
because it's less likely does it still
have an impact on that date when we
might feel like life is back to normal
i think it'll have an impact in two ways
yeah it will definitely have an impact
on the date when we feel like things are
normal again
one because you know getting kids
vaccinated will
will be really important to just
decreasing the number of people getting
sick
um we've got to get that population that
can still transmit the virus protected
from getting sick and from being able to
spread it to others
the other way that it's going to be
impactful is that
we won't be able to lift restrictions
for kids we won't be able
to reduce some of the the measures that
are in place now for protection
until those kids are vaccinated so if we
want to get back to normal we've got to
protect
everybody and that that includes the
pediatric population too
what do you wish that parents of this
age group 12 to 15 year olds understood
about the vaccine yeah
yeah that's so important i i
i just want parents to know that it is
possible for their kids to get sick with
this disease
i i see a lot of parents in my clinic
who are doing all the right things you
know they're
having their kids wear masks they're
being very you know cautious and
concerned
and and i think that um so many parents
have been working so hard to keep their
kids safe over this last year
but everybody just needs to remember
that it is possible for kids to get sick
for them to transmit the virus
and i want them to know too how
how thoroughly experts are looking at
these vaccines
how carefully they're testing them in
all
age groups right now these trials that
are going on in the pediatric population
are testing all age groups down to six
months they're making sure that they're
testing for the appropriate dose to give
kids
we're monitoring side effects so so
closely
so when it comes time for younger and
younger kids
to be offered the vaccine i want them to
know that that
physicians scientists everybody involved
in this process
feels really confident that it's safe
and one kind of moral question that's
come from this decision
to or upcoming decision to uh increase
eligibility of the shots is this idea
that the u.s
has too many that we have taken more of
our share that
along with a lot of wealthy countries
around the world that we've scooped up
more shots than we need for our
population
do you think that we should have chosen
to
ship these shots over to india for
example
before we opened them up to opened up 12
to 15 year olds to get the shots
yeah that that is that is a really
compelling
question right now um you know when we
look back at just three weeks ago
we were getting over 3 million people
a day on average vaccinated there was a
really big demand and a high
volume usage of our vaccines and now
we're seeing it
you know tapering off and we're around 2
million now
so i don't know that i could say we
missed the mark and
you know and a month ago or two months
ago
um you know we did something that we
shouldn't have done but
i think now as we move forward we
that is a huge hugely important question
and if we're not using the vaccines
that are available now i feel like it is
really important to get those to the
places that are suffering we know what
that feels like
we've been through it we know what it
feels like when hospital systems are
overwhelmed
we know what it feels like when family
members die from this disease
and when we see it happening elsewhere
in the world it just
makes sense to reach out and help if we
have doses sitting on the shelf
further you know in addition to
to the idea that it just seems like the
right thing to do
you know people have to also understand
that we will never
get beyond this virus in our own country
if we don't
deal with it in other parts of the world
so it makes sense to send doses to other
countries
yep yep well we will certainly be
following the biden administration's
decisions on that biden tease that
earlier today
uh dr susannah hills really appreciate
you joining us on that thank you
scarlett meantime the source of that
surplus of vaccines pfizer
is laying out a plan to turn its coven
19 vaccine into a long-term business
it has clinched agreements that will
yield 26 billion dollars in sales
this year that is up more than 70
percent from its previous forecast
the drug maker says it now expects to
deliver 1.6 billion doses
in 2021. pfizer will also ramp up its r
d
spending to invest in cova treatments
and other mrna based
vaccines now this investment comes as
ceo albert berla
bets that covet 19 will require people
to get regular shots for years to come
we've seen pfizer's stock climb almost 9
percent this year trailing the s p
500. in other covid news the world's 20
major economies are throwing their
weight behind
efforts to introduce vaccine passports a
draft statement from the g20 nations
seen by bloomberg stresses the
importance of resuming travel
and tourism to get economies growing
once again new legislation in germany
giving
more freedom to fully vaccinated people
is now coming under fire
the so-called jab to freedom bill lifts
social distancing rules and curfews for
some people
but critics say the new rules which kick
in this weekend unfairly excludes
younger people who are not
yet eligible to get the vaccine and
argentina's highest court overruled the
president's decree to shut schools
because of a surge in infections
according to the ruling tuesday alberto
fernandez's decision to close schools in
buenos aires
violates
overseas as code 19 ravages india
artisin robbie shares some of their
stories
millions of indians around the world are
watching in horror as
india reaches record numbers of kovid19
infections
ankur chandra a new york resident
struggles to find ways to support his
relatives overseas
then we learned a 32 year old kid
uh in our apartment complex past room
corona it happened
two days gone his mother is sick then
one of her first cousin in another part
of the city
he got really sick relatively young and
he was on ventilator and then he passed
away then i was like man
this is getting serious as the death
toll rises to more than 200 000 deaths
the 4.2 million indian americans that
make up the diaspora
can only help from afar due to the do
not travel advisory issued by the state
department
many of them can only wait for bad news
to reach them through a barrage of
whatsapp messages
a call or a social media post it will
affect families i agree
because the india dysphoria is still
having where
a lot of people immigrated to united
states but not you know
the parents are still back in india uh
they're they're they're
somebody's wife is still back in india
so you know so so there's still
that disconnect you know on that and
before covert you know people were
trawling back and forth and visiting
each other but now it's become very
difficult
images of hospitals overflowing with the
sick and dying are flooding social media
as medical staff and public alike make
desperate appeals for oxygen supplies
in the uk british indian communities
took part in a 48-hour bike relay
covering the distance from london to new
delhi in an attempt to raise money to
help with the kovit 19 situation
in india i think as british indians it's
you know it's been quite distressing for
us to see what's been going on at home
and of course we can't be there
physically in the time we're in at the
moment
and due to that we're just doing a
little bit away from home
i guess it can't escape me that there's
quite a lot of a dire situation in india
right now
you know as an indian i've got friends
and family or in india i cannot do
anything
for them directly so you know it's an
opportunity to do something by cycling
so
certainly you know raise some good money
which i didn't expect
at a grad school things you feel very
helpless and you walk evaluating and
watching
uh everything by the minute and you know
you can call your parents
call your loved ones to see how they're
doing but there's only so much you can
do right now
if they get sick and events are not
available if the oxygen is not available
what can you do right now so that's
always on the back of your mind right
now
as life in the uk and the us edges back
to normal the unequal access to vaccines
is also becoming more evident for
indians abroad
only two percent of the people in india
have been fully vaccinated
compared with the 30 percent in the us
and 21
in the uk according to the bloomberg
vaccine tracker
we were reassured like in january
february oh coroner is always
over so people still took the guards off
so that is the most frustrating thing
that after one year
you know you still have to call like all
the countries that please send aid and
everything when you were saying
we have enough it that's the most
frustrating part
for the latest coveted news bookmark
bloomberg.com forward slash
coronavirus maddie still ahead on quick
take the lead we'll explain why fast
food giants are ramping up climate
commitments
as they see their current supply chains
buckle under a wide range of shortages
this is quicktake the lead
[Music]
so
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists policy
makers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
the ongoing chicken sandwich wars has
resulted in a poultry shortage here in
the u.s
at the same time poor yields on potatoes
are setting us up for a potential french
fry shortage as well both of which are
staples for consumers devoted to their
fast food chains maddie is shaking her
head there
thanks to popeyes chick-fil-a kfc and
mcdonald's
chicken is now the most popular meat in
the u.s but the resultant poultry
shortage could lead to increased
consumer demand for plant-based options
and push fast food companies to
decarbonize their supply chains
artie ramachandran is director of
research and engagement at the
fa irr initiative it's an investor
network focusing on esg risks in the
global food sector
artie welcome to quick take you've done
a lot of interesting research on the
industry but i want to start with these
shortages that i mentioned
how does your group think about the
increasing frequency of certain food
shortages and
what does it say about supply chains um
thank you for having me scarlett
um i think it emphasizes a point that
we've been making for a while now which
is
that um the food sector broadly but
certainly
animal protein supply chains meat and
dairy supply chains
are deeply vulnerable to climate related
disruption and so when i talk about
disruption i'm talking about
more droughts uh you know higher
frequency and severity of extreme
weather events and how that plays out
into
into supply chains so some of the food
shortages that you're talking about
right now are linked
to global weather related events that
have played out in higher feed input
costs
in some cases they've increased the the
you know
the inflation pressures on on livestock
producers and that obviously has wider
implications for
for the entire economy so absolutely
absolutely
so i do want to get to your research now
because you've learned so much and
you've tracked how investor engagement
with six
fast food chains um is leading them to
increase their climate commitments
what does that actually mean in practice
what does it look like
well i think to begin with i think we've
been really pleased to see that
um some of these companies now um you
know have are
you know their boards are more engaged
on the issue of climate-related risk
they now are beginning to acknowledge
that climate related risk will have an
impact on their supply chains and you
know in their annual filings and then
financial filings
um i think what's been really really
encouraging to see is that
when we started this engagement two two
years ago we had uh maybe two
commitments
um two companies with climate-related
commitments and that has now
sort of widened to six companies all six
companies and the engagements either
have set commitments or
they plan to set um climate quite
ambitious climate related
uh commitments encompassing their entire
values so that's right
and these are some of the biggest
changes as well whether it's mcdonald's
yum brands chipotle domino's
and wendy's of course when you talk
about some of the
commitments that they're making they can
set aggressive targets for instance they
can undertake risk scenario analysis
these are all easy to recommend and
relatively easy for companies to
implement as well but it doesn't
necessarily lead to desired outcomes
how do you jump over the hurdle of
getting companies to make the actual
operational changes to
create meaningful outcome well the
global
fast food sector is a 600 billion dollar
behemoth scholar so i don't want to
downplay the challenge and we have
extremely
complex um supply chain so it is it is
you know it is the challenge
that faces these companies is extensive
um they're going to have to implement
these targets and policies and very
opaque supply chains
so it is certainly a challenge for them
but i think you mentioned um you know
sort of diversification into plant-based
options and that does
you know present a really exciting
opportunity for companies
both from a risk perspective but also
from
a a growth perspective last year in the
u.s pump is
food sales increased by something like
43 percent
year on year so that was nine times
faster than
total food sales so it really is a
fantastic opportunities
for companies to de-risk their supply
chains while jumping on the bad angle of
a group now one area that you've noticed
where the companies are falling short
is when it comes to water they haven't
really done enough to address water
scarcity issues
as well as pollution why is this such an
in why is this such a challenge
well part of it is the scale of of meat
and dairy farming in the u.s i mean it's
extensive
um it's you know sort of quite
underregulated
um it produces tons millions of tons of
manure um
that really is applied to surrounding
farms there's extensive problem with
like water quality issues and
you know sort of has implications for
wildlife and biodiversity
um for for areas surrounding these farms
and for the communities that live around
these farms so it is
it is becoming a serious issue and it is
one that
you know we expect to see growing
regulation on um because as i said it
has been
rather under regulated but that will
change and for
investors want to start seeing companies
work with their suppliers on on
addressing water quality and water
scarcity issues because it is a key
input and it is a risk in terms of
license to operate as well for many of
these companies
so when you look at these companies and
the action that they're taking how much
of it would you say is reactive versus
proactive and when do you see that
that balance tipping to proactive in the
next couple of years
i think we'd say it's reactive um
certainly i think it's in response to
engagements like like this one um you
know encouraging companies to start
really looking at seriously at the risk
of climate change and what implications
that will have for their own business
models and product portfolios
um i think you know we are seeing um
sort of more proactive action being
taken
by by companies that are in the retail
and the manufacturing segments they've
sort of definitely ahead in the game um
and so i think the fast food sector has
a little catching up too
got it artie ramachandran of the fair
initiative joining us from london thank
you so much for staying up late and
giving us some of your insights really
appreciate it maddie
let's get you a look at some other
headlines making news around the world a
metro collapse in mexico city
has left at least 24 dead and more than
70 people
injured the incident marks one of the
deadliest episodes in the history of the
city subway system
the accident was caused by a beam
collapsing as the train passed over it
on monday night
mexico city's metro is one of the
busiest in the world
and in germany berlin police have
arrested a 53 year old man with alleged
ties to a neo-nazi group
the man is accused of sending almost 100
threatening letters to politicians
lawyers and journalists
the arrest comes as local officials warn
of the growing threat of violent
far-right extremism in the country last
year germany recorded a near
73 percent increase in anti-immigrant
crimes
and almost 16 percent increase in
anti-semitic crimes as well
and the g7 is considering a u.s proposal
to counter china's economic coercion
the biden administration suggested a
consultation mechanism that would
involve the g7
and others to ensure coordinated
response to the asian superpower
other global challenges under discussion
include myanmar russia
ukraine and a problem for a lot of
nations the spread of disinformation
for the latest news from your part of
the world go to bloomberg.com click on
the addition drop down
right next to the bloomberg masthead and
choose your region scarlett
all right coming up after the break here
in the u.s minorities many of whom were
hammered by the pandemic are now being
left behind
in recovery we found out what's driving
the growing economic divide
next this is quick take the lead
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry uh buildings
electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the u.s economy is achieving a
remarkably fast recovery from the
recession
that ripped through the nation last year
the first quarter of 2021 saw the
strongest gdp growth in nearly
two decades but this expansion is
obscuring local pain
with minorities in some cities finding
themselves left behind by the overall
boom and hiring that we're seeing
take a look at this chart about the
unemployment rate that's broken down by
race by the fall the coveted pandemic
had
more than doubled the difference between
white and black unemployment
and widened the white versus hispanic
gap in unemployment by 2.3 percentage
points
so this underscores a very uneven
recovery
how could all of this data play into
federal and monetary policy moving
forward though
joining us to discuss is one of the
reporters tracking the economic recovery
in communities across the country
olivia rockman olivia thank you for
joining us
obviously this has a huge impact on the
individual lives that we're talking
about beyond these unemployment numbers
but
it also has a big impact on the federal
level can you talk about why this
matters
more broadly in the u.s yeah
fed chair jerome powell has said that
he's tracking alternative measures of
unemployment
and labor that includes the black
unemployment rate
and wage growth for low-income workers
and so when we dive down and look at
this data
on the metro level we see that you know
there really are wide differences and
that really if powell is looking at it
as he says he is affects interest rates
and affects how the fed's going to move
in the coming months
so i want to dig into a couple of
specific data points that you bring up
in your piece
starting with the unemployment gap that
we see widening and difference between
white and black americans and i know
that in your reporting you also found
that that difference is even more stark
when you look at the numbers for black
women in particular can you talk a
little bit about those numbers
yeah a lot of this comes from industry
level
situations for people of color in the
united states
as we know there's a lot of systemic
issues that
mean many black americans are in
low-wage jobs so for example
many black women work in you know
child care centers that had to close
down or in
grocery stores that haven't fared as
well and so
that's sort of why we're seeing that gap
widen now
something else we're tracking is as you
mentioned black women and that's
something that powell has talked about
as well
and for that group specifically they
tend to be in the most front line jobs
which have been hard hit
and there is one state in particular in
your data that's kind of
something we can look to as a beacon of
hope i guess you could say
in arizona the gap is quite a bit lower
can you talk about
what they're doing right and whether
that could be replicated more broadly
across the u.s
yeah in phoenix we saw that one of the
reasons the hispanic americans there
have recovered
better than other groups is because many
are employed in construction
and housing has been booming and so
that's been really helpful for
the unemployment rate for that group now
in the meantime
there's also a lot of hispanic-owned
businesses in phoenix and
there were a large number of ppp loans
that went to those individuals and so
overall that community has recovered
strongly
in terms of looking at other communities
it really is just this interesting
cultural and social sort of setup in
phoenix and so it'll be interesting to
see
kind of how things change elsewhere to
match that
so it sounds like these numbers are
really specific to some of the
industries here but i also want to talk
about this idea that
we're still not back to a pre-pandemic
normal
however the gap was always there even
before the pandemic this wasn't normal
we saw this gap based on race in
particular
what do you make of that gap
yeah we already had a 2.2 percentage
point gap between black and white
americans before the pandemic
and so you know even when we get to a
quote unquote recovery
that would still imply that we have a
gap and so it'll be super interesting to
see that once all of these pandemic
problems kind of lift off so schools
reopen
offices reopen people are vaccinated um
you know whether that gap is still 2.2
percent
is it wider than that is it narrower
and maybe there are some pandemic
effects that linger longer for
you know minority groups i am not a math
girl olivia i have to admit to you but
uh hear me out here if you kind of is
there a way to when you're doing
these calculations to account for the
differences
in the type of industries that one
racial group may be more likely to be
part of
to really suss out how much of this is a
racial
dynamic in hiring that we're seeing
across the u.s is there a way to kind of
figure that out mathematically so we
haven't been doing that for this metro
data specifically however
we do track the jobs report which is
coming up this friday and
we are able to break down by race and
industry
and so it is something that we're
watching as i mentioned for you know
black women
kind of looking at what industries that
they're in and how quickly they're
recovering
olivia thank you so much for joining us
we'll have to look at how all this data
changes when unemployment benefits do
expire
this september so we'll probably have
you back then olivia really appreciate
it
scarlett coming up after the break a new
initiative
brewing to help victims of gun violence
we'll explain what we mean when we're
back in two
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
we turn now to a somber story that has
one small business
trying to turn tragedy into good in
march 10 people were killed and others
injured when a man opened fire in a
boulder colorado supermarket
the community came together but it was
another unimaginable mass shooting that
left
so many grieving one local brewery
upslope brewing company wanted to do
something to help
the victims of this tragedy that brewery
is offering up what it does best and may
be a model for how companies can step in
and have an
impact matt cutter is the president of
upslope brewing and he
joins us now matt thank you for being
here i want to start with
this initiative tell me a little bit
about how it works and
what you're doing sure maddie so
um uh when the tragedy uh struck boulder
you know you often have those feelings
that you need to do something
what can we do how can we contribute how
can we
uh help anybody who went through this
situation so
we uh we worked with our team and we
started reaching out to
local boulder county businesses which um
you know
boulder the city of boulder's 100 000
people maybe about a quarter million
people in baltimore county
but a very tight-knit bus tight-knit
business community
so we started uh getting ideas of like
okay could we put together
something that would support the
families of the victims
so we reached out to a number of
local craft breweries in boulder county
they all immediately jumped on board
also a local canning company called
cannimel
and fortnight collective which is a
brand and marketing
uh company so we got together
and uh we came up with this idea the
colorado care cam
the concept is each of these breweries
would contribute one of the cans out of
a six pack
and we put the six packs together uh
with the branding
that fortnight collective put together
and um
cannibal who who uh could do the do the
cans for us
and we would sell these mixed six packs
out of each of the tap rooms of the six
butler county breweries
and then a hundred percent of the
proceeds would go with the colorado
healing fund
wow really really amazing work that you
all are doing now of course
this is something that's plagued the
boulder area like you mentioned matt but
i'm curious
what made you decide to take action here
is there something that makes this fight
personal for you
yes so i didn't personally know
any of these victims or these families
um
it was surprising to me because it is
such a tight-knit community
but we decided uh you know we we had
some ideas of how we should react how we
should contribute
what could we do and then it was our
it was really our marketing folks that
came up with this idea
um these are these are people prob
probably these people
and their families have been to our tap
rooms in boulder county
um so it's it's just kind of what we do
as as uh as craft breweries do
you know when there's a need you know
where there's some come in the community
um we are in the communities so
we're it's just natural for us to jump
in and help where we can
i'm so glad that you bring that up matt
because i have this sense that brewery
activism is sort of its own genre i i
think back to the beginning of covid
when so many local breweries were
supplying hand sanitizer to their
communities
what do you make of this idea of this
kind of community of fellow beer
lovers sort of getting together and
really
you know rolling up their sleeves and
and working to make
the world a better place yeah i think
it's um
i think it's actually something that
comes very natural to
us it's it's something that's uh part of
our dna
as a craft brewery you know we support
our communities
when there are not tragedies going on we
support local
non-profits somebody uh
somebody has a need in the community
okay how can how can we be creative
and and help out and and when i reach
out
to these local boulder businesses and
uh in the breweries i mean nobody
hesitated
it was like yeah yeah of course
of course what what can we do how can we
contribute tell us what to do next
so what do you wish more broadly that
other business leaders who are listening
to this
would take away from uh kind of the
lesson that you're sharing in the work
that you're doing do you think that
other
business leaders should look at this as
an example of you know there's no act
too small that you can always do
something to help
yes absolutely we we all have ways in
which we contribute
uh with our own businesses our employees
our business partners
um i think it just takes you know uh
you know hitting the pause button a
little bit and and taking the time to
collect your thoughts and think
oh okay i think i know some people who
can help with this
and we could have this going and and we
could raise money this way
for the families of the victims and
contribute in the best way we can
maybe it's with maybe it's with their
local products maybe it's
uh by writing a check maybe it's uh some
other ways of support
depending on you know who these
businesses are i mean it could be as
simple as a local florist that could
offer up
flowers to the to the families of the
victims um i
i think all can contribute matt cutter
president of upslope brewing company
really appreciate you being here to
share your work
scarlett what a heartfelt conversation
brewery activism i love that
all right let's get you to today's
movers and shakers these are the people
impacting the world of business politics
and sports
jessica alba's personal care brand the
honest company is aiming for a valuation
of more than one and a half billion
dollars in its initial public offering
the ipo could give alba who's the
co-founder a stake valued
at around 96 million dollars honest
company is classified as an emerging
growth company which means it doesn't
have to make the same kinds of
disclosures
typically required of bigger companies
when it goes public
one of soccer's most outspoken coaches
jose mourinho will take over the next
season
at as roma the soccer club's surprise
announcement today is a welcome sign for
a team that hasn't won italy's top
league
for two decades news of mourinho's
hiring sent roma stock up by as much as
26
and republican congresswoman liz chaney
testing the patience of her colleagues
according to axios house minority leader
kevin mccarthy was caught on a hot mic
saying that he's lost confidence in her
it comes as top republicans turn on
cheney the gop's highest ranking woman
in congress
with at least once conservative leader
suggesting that she could be ousted from
the party
within a month and those are today's
movers and shakers
now coming up after the break remember
alamo drafthouse
it's coming back after filing for
bankruptcy we're going to speak with the
cinema chain's founder about what the
future of theaters look like
in the streaming era stay with us
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
this is the difference
summer movie season just around the
corner but after 2020 that changed life
as we know it
the movie industry is confronting change
and uncertainty many theater chains were
forced to shut their doors after months
of closures
some permanently in our weekly dive into
the business of entertainment we are
looking at one chain poised for a
comeback in this new landscape
alamo drafthouse cinema founder and
executive chairman tim league
joins us now from austin texas tim
welcome to quick take i know
it's been a crazy busy week for you a
bankruptcy judge approved alamo's plan
to be sold to a group that
includes you personally and lenders and
this group has agreed to forgive about
60 million dollars of debt
tell me how all this sets up alamo for
its next phase
well it's it's been certainly an
interesting year for not just us but the
whole industry
but we're we are turning the page so
what that does basically is we're
coming into the second half of this year
with a relatively clean balance sheet we
have new investment
and we're also seeing the industry start
to come back to life
like uh every weekend is better than the
last there weren't even new movies out
this past weekend really
and it was a very very strong weekend so
we see
hope and optimism and honestly
opportunities so we're going to continue
our path
to grow okay so i'm going to pick up on
what you just said there because i think
about 10 draft house theaters are
already open you're aiming to get that
to 30 by july
but what exactly are you showing if
there's no new films coming out and we
know the big studios are waiting until
the official start of summer to really
release their big movies
what will your theaters be showing in
the meantime
well really since the beginning uh we've
had a pretty diverse slate of films
so in in 2019 for example we played
around
2100 different movies at alamo whereas
you know the the bigger change they're
usually playing about 300 or so 400
movies
so what that means is we've built up an
audience for
interesting films and so about 70
percent of our business
is derived from big blockbusters about
20 comes from
more independent uh fair and then
10 comes from alternative content
whether that's rep
or sports or anything any kind of event
that's not a movie
and so in these times where that 70
percent was smaller
we leaned out and we heavier and heavier
into classic films and
alternative content and um we're going
to continue to do that
for for the rest of the year gotcha
classic films and alternative content
you mentioned investments and how coming
out of bankruptcy will allow you to
make more investments we've obviously
come a long way from last march but
covid has not gone away
talk a little bit about the spending
that you'll be doing when it comes to
mitigating the risk of exposure for
moviegoers will there be sitting changes
will there be changes made to your food
ordering system
yeah so we we reopened very cautiously
and uh did so after we hit our own bar
so our
our internal metric was we're going to
be safer than the supermarket
and so we took out a lot of things and
changed our model
so we shut down the box office it's
online ticketing only
we built a online ordering mechanism so
you could order in advance
so you could theoretically come to the
theater uh do your temp
check and do your check-in and not
touch another surface other than your
butt hitting the seat and then
leave and have a really really safe
experience
and so that's still currently where we
are um and
my my suspicion is you know the the
vaccine rollout has been great
and you know as we reach that point
where
everybody in the united states has had
access to the vaccine
that to me triggers the point where okay
um
uh now everybody has the opportunity to
be vaccinated significant percentage of
folks have been
so we'll return to normal you know we're
estimating that's hopefully
in in q3 later this year and we'll we'll
be cautious up until that point
gotcha gotcha there's always been some
speculation among industry watchers that
theaters were
are going to have to start offering more
of a premium experience
on the other side of this pandemic to
really entice audiences to come back
even with all the safety precautions
that you just laid out
your chain is known for its food for its
lux seating
and for the strict no phones policy
which i applaud
but that was before the pandemic what do
you think it'll take
now in terms of offering new experiences
to keep people coming back in
on a consistent basis well for us that's
really been our core product right i
i came into this business as a total
outsider with no
experience other than really loving
movies and
we've carried that forward now i have
you know some experience
but um you know the idea of premium
it's not always premium what we want to
do is just make sure that
every touch point we have with our
guests from from the website to entering
the door
to sitting down to the food you eat the
drinks to the quality of the
presentation like everything is
beautiful
and worth getting out of the home so you
know there's
there's been a lot of talk about about
streamers and the effect that's going to
have on the industry and
i don't i don't really see it that way i
see
we're in the out of home entertainment
business and so
we need to ensure that if you make a
decision to leave the home
that you've made the right one and
you're you're dazzled by the movies
when they're at their best so we're
gonna we're gonna keep up what we've
always done
and and we've been working in the lab
with a few few new tricks ah
okay i knew there would be some tricks
in there very quickly here tim
um when it comes to warner brothers
shaking up the industry and releasing
its movies at the same time on hbo max
and at the theaters
is that an experiment or here to stay
i think it is uh some
level of it is here to stay i think it
is an experiment i think
that when theaters are at its uh our
fullest capacity
that we're going to earn our spots and
there will be a
an exclusive window for almost all
movies that come through right
but that said we've always been in the
business with folks who have done
day-to-day releases and that's more in
the independent sector
uh we've had a relationship with netflix
and we did very well with the scorsese
film and with roma
right um so we're we're open to it and
we we
we treat it all in in the vein of
partnership
i i think it'll stabilize with uh
something of a more like
what universal has the 17-day exclusive
window or something along those lines
tim leake really appreciate your time
and sharing your thoughts with us
founder and executive chairman of alamo
drafthouse cinema
maddie let's get you look at some other
top tech headlines from the day
crypto watchers saw a new trick from
dogecoin
the dog themed cryptocurrency that
started as a joke climbed as much as
50 today trading around 58 cents
and sending the value of all dogecoin to
about 75
billion dollars wow the surge also
triggered errors for crypto traders on
the robin hood app
and as a reminder all this comes just
days before dogecoin proponent and tesla
ceo elon musk is going to host
snl so we'll all be watching that on
saturday
and things are looking up for lyft the
ride share company released quarterly
earnings signaling
brighter days ahead lift reported lower
losses than expected
73 million dollars versus analyst
estimates of 143 million dollars
the company says that airport rides
airport rides rather were up
65 in recent weeks compared to january
and it's on track to be profitable by
the third quarter
and more bad news for cyberpunk they
can't get away from it one of its top
directors has resigned from
studio after facing allegations of
workplace bullying
conrad tamaskowitz served as a second
director on december's
negatively received cyberpunk he's
denied the bullying allegations but
apologized for quote all the bad blood i
have caused
for the latest tech news
bookmarkbloomberg.com forward slash
and coming up after the break the video
game industry thrived in the
in the pandemic wow i'm struggling today
can the success continue we'll speak
with the ceo of a business providing
high performance gear for gamers about
what the future holds
stay with us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about apple's battle with the
maker of fortnite which is now entering
day two today in federal court epic
games is alleging that apple's app store
leaves users and developers trapped in
an anti-competitive marketplace
but the iphone maker is hitting back
accusing epic of a fundamental assault
on a business model
that's helped millions of developers
here's ed ludlow with the latest
epic's attorneys spent the first day of
the trial trying to secure the moral
high ground
saying that apple had monopolistic
powers and the ios
and the app store were a walled garden
where only apple
controlled the rules epic ceo tim
sweeney took the stand as well on monday
and said that this was a lawsuit quote
entirely about apple's practices
he was talking about how the apple store
policies actually prevented epic
from being able to add features to
popular titles
like fortnite for example and he pointed
out that when it comes to
the commissions that apple charge
charges in a range of 15 to 30 percent
on each download apple is making more
profit
on those downloads than the developers
are themselves that is something
that apple's attorney shot down saying
that many other
platforms and competitors out there
charge similar commission fees
they also shot down epic's arguments
about how it would be beneficial for the
consumer if there were more competition
or if there were a change to ios rules
apple really emphasized the security
and anti-fraud protections that come
with the
app store payment system as an example
and it also pointed out
that 84 of the apps that are on the app
store
are free to download and that there is a
varying rate of commission especially
for the smaller companies
or smaller developers where apple
charges a lower rate
uh we expect to hear from the app store
chief phil schiller
in the coming weeks along with tim cook
the apple ceo but this has got a long
way to run and really
monday was about setting out each side's
grievances
and particular pressure points of where
they think the judge in oakland can be
convinced ed ludlow bloomberg news
san francisco
and again that was bloomberg's ed ludlow
scarlett
well the pandemic has given everyone
from casual gamers to professional
esporters
an excuse to upgrade their gear how's
that playing out for makers of that gear
andy paul ceo and president of corsair
which went public last september
joins us now andy lockdowns are easing
summer's approaching people are
traveling they're at least leaving the
house have we reached peak gaming do you
think
well far from it i think we're in the
middle of a
a steady growth period which is you know
a couple of decades long
so what we've been through in the last
year is really a period where
people were already gaming have just
learned to game
better and that's encouraged them to buy
you know some gear a lot of it from us a
lot of it from you
how dependent are you on activision and
other video game publishers posting big
sales i mean to what extent do people
buy their gear
based on new game releases or new
console releases or is it more of a
steady drum beat
it's actually a steady drum beat there's
no question that
when a game comes out like fortnight um
you know back in 2018 we saw a surge of
activity but
the activity surge tends to be in
entry-level products like gaming
headsets
most of the things that we sell are you
know
two thousand dollar gaming pcs or
components to build them
uh and so that's not really uh affected
by you know
one game or another gotcha well you
mentioned that high price point what
about gaming on mobile devices your
competitors have released these
controller cases that give phones joy
pads and buttons
do you have any interest in exploring
this space yeah i think so
i mean we've concentrated on the high
end so far
on a pc gaming and recently about a year
ago we bought a um
a company called scuf gaming that makes
very high performance uh
console controllers and i think it's
quite likely that we'll move into the
uh mobile space but you know it's a much
lower price and uh
yeah less populated uh area what about
content
i and i asked because microsoft was in
talks before it abandoned it to buy
discord um how does social media
platform
fit in with the rest of your business
well it's an integral part of it in fact
i i think of it the other way that
gaming is starting to become the
the the social platform uh if you like
of
people hanging out there's a lot of
discussion these days of gaming being
the third
place where people hang out after work
and after their home
and so that's really where people a lot
of young people are hanging out
in games uh just to socialize with each
other got it very quickly here someone
on twitter
announced suggested that you maybe go
into a deal with uh gamestop which is
certainly in the zeitgeist
uh would that be a yay or nay uh we're
already selling in uh in gamestop our
stuff controllers
but we have a very uh solid distribution
platform right now for all our existing
retailers and retailers so
uh yeah if gamestop wants to sell pc
gear that would be great
andy paul thank you so much founder and
ceo of corsair which makes those
gaming keyboards that my son is so fond
of that does it for a quick take this
hour be sure to check us out on at quick
tips on social media
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coming up on quick take the lead
president biden sets a new vaccine goal
but demand is slowing in parts of the
u.s
what is the white house doing to get
more shots into arms
then the u.s economy is heating up again
as cities and states reopen
but bloomberg analysis shows minorities
are being left behind
we'll talk with a reporter shining light
on inclusive recovery in the aftermath
of covid19
and will there be enough action at the
box office to make movies into summer
blockbusters
is the world ready to head back inside
theaters
it is tuesday may 4th what do they say
maddie may the fourth be with you
be with you i'm scarlett fo and i'm
madison mills those stories and more
coming up on quick take the lead
[Music]
we start with the coronavirus vaccine
hesitancy in the u.s
is slowing the pace of inoculations
president biden is now trying to change
that he hopes to get 70 percent of adult
americans vaccinated by july 4th
we know that many adults have not been
vaccinated because they have found it
too confusing or too difficult or too
inconvenient to get a shot
so for those having trouble finding a
location or making an appointment
we're going to make it easier than ever
the administration is also looking to
open up eligibility to adolescence
u.s health regulators are expected to
clear the pfizer shop for use among
12 to 15 year olds and that could happen
as early as this week
so how could that decision affect our
race to hurt immunity that magical
moment when the world might feel a
little more normal
joining us to discuss this is dr
susannah hills
a pediatric airway surgeon and associate
professor at
columbia medical school doctor thank you
for being here
to start could you explain why is it
important for this group
to get vaccinated because i feel like
the whole narrative
has been that kids are fine so why is it
still
crucial to get this group of people the
shots
this is something that we really need to
be talking about
now as we're making this push to get
closer to herd immunity um
kids are gonna are gonna make up a more
and more significant part of the
unvaccinated
population as more adults get vaccinated
and they make up 22 percent of the u.s
population
so we will never if we're looking to
achieve herd immunity which is
you know about 80 or maybe even more
um we're thinking now because this new
b117 variant is even more transmissible
we may need more people vaccinated to
get hurt immunity
that large group of pediatric people
is gonna make a significant portion of
our population and they really need to
get vaccinated
besides all of that though you know i
i've got to be honest with you guys you
know being
an airway surgeon here at this hospital
i just don't
want to have to put another surgical
breathing tube
in another child who is sick with this
disease
i don't want to see another sick kid in
my clinic
um and you know we've been talking all
along about the kids or
how kids are less affected but i have to
tell you we're seeing kids get sick and
we're seeing them get really sick
thank you for sharing that doctor so i'm
curious do you think
that getting this group vaccinated is
going to really help us
in that timeline right because again
you know i know i hear you saying that
some kids are still getting
sick but because it's less likely does
it still have an
impact on that date when we might feel
like life is back to normal
i think it'll have an impact in two ways
yeah it will definitely have an impact
on the date when we feel like things are
normal again one because
you know getting kids vaccinated will
will be really important to just
decreasing the number of people getting
sick um we've got to get
that population that can still transmit
the virus protected
from getting sick and from being able to
spread it to others
the other way that it's going to be
impactful is that
we won't be able to lift restrictions
for kids we won't be able
to reduce some of the the measures that
are in place now for protection
until those kids are vaccinated so if we
want to get back to normal we've got to
protect
everybody and that that includes the
pediatric population too
what do you wish that parents of this
age group 12 to 15 year olds understood
about the vaccine yeah
yeah that's so important i i
i just want parents to know that it is
possible for their kids to get sick with
this disease
i i see a lot of parents in my clinic
who are doing all the right things you
know they're
having their kids wear masks they're
being very you know cautious and
concerned
and and i think that um so many parents
have been working so hard to keep their
kids safe over this last year
but everybody just needs to remember
that it is possible for kids to get sick
for them to transmit the virus
and i want them to know too how
how thoroughly experts are looking at
these
vaccines how carefully they're testing
them
in all age groups right now these trials
that are going on in the pediatric
population
are testing all age groups down to six
months they're making sure that they're
testing for the appropriate dose to give
kids
we're monitoring side effects so so
closely
so when it comes time for younger and
younger kids
to be offered the vaccine i want them to
know that that
physicians scientists everybody involved
in this process
feels really confident that it's safe
and one kind of moral question that's
come from this decision
to or upcoming decision to increase
eligibility of the shots is this idea
that the u.s
has too many that we have taken more of
our share that
along with a lot of wealthy countries
around the world that we've scooped up
more shots than we need for our
population
do you think that we should have chosen
to
ship these shots over to india for
example
before we opened them up to open up 12
to 15 year olds to
get the shots yeah that that is
that is a really compelling question
right now
um you know when we look back at just
three weeks ago
we were getting over 3 million
people a day on average vaccinated there
was a really big demand and a high
volume usage of our vaccines and now
we're seeing it
you know tapering off and we're around 2
million now
so i don't know that i could say we
missed the mark and
you know and a month ago or two months
ago
um you know we did something that we
shouldn't have done but
i think now as we move forward
we we that is a huge hugely important
question
and if we're not using the vaccines that
are available now
i feel like it is really important to
get those to the places that are
suffering we know what that feels like
we've been through it
we know what it feels like when hospital
systems are overwhelmed we know
what it feels like when family members
die from this disease and when we see it
happening elsewhere in the world
it just makes sense to reach out and
help if we have doses sitting on the
shelf
further you know in addition to
to the idea that it just seems like the
right thing to do
you know people have to also understand
that we will never
get beyond this virus in our own country
if we don't
deal with it in other parts of the world
so it makes sense to send doses to other
countries
yep yep well we will certainly be
following the biden administration's
decisions on that biden tease that
earlier today
uh dr suzanna hills really appreciate
you joining us on that thank you
scarlett meantime the source of that
surplus of vaccines pfizer
is laying out a plan to turn its coved
19 vaccine into a long-term business
it has clinched agreements that will
yield 26 billion dollars in sales
this year that is up more than 70
percent from its previous forecast
the maker says it now expects to deliver
1.6 billion doses
in 2021. pfizer will also ramp up its r
d spending to invest in cova treatments
and other
mrna-based vaccines now this investment
comes as ceo albert berla
bets that covet 19 will require people
to get regular shots for years to come
we've seen pfizer's stock climb almost 9
this year trailing the s p 500.
in other covid news the world's 20 major
economies are throwing their weight
behind
efforts to introduce vaccine passports a
draft statement from the g20 nations
seen by bloomberg stresses the
importance of resuming travel
and tourism to get economies growing
once again new legislation in germany
giving more freedom to fully vaccinated
people
is now coming under fire the so-called
jab to freedom bill
lifts social distancing rules and
curfews for some people
but critics say the new rules which kick
in this weekend unfairly excludes
younger people who are not yet eligible
to get the vaccine
and argentina's highest court overruled
the president's decree to shut schools
because of a surge in infections
according to the ruling tuesday alberto
fernandez's decision to close schools in
buenos aires
violates that city's autonomy the city's
mayor has argued there's little evidence
that in-person classes
increase infection rates and millions of
indians across the globe one of the
world's largest diasporas are struggling
to help their relatives overseas
as code 19 ravages india artisin robbie
shares some
of their stories millions of indians
around the world are watching in horror
as india reaches record numbers of
kovid19 infections
ankur chandra a new york resident
struggles to find ways to support his
relatives overseas
then we learned a 32 year old kid
in our apartment complex past room
corona it happened two days
gone his mother is sick then one of her
first cousin
in other part of the city he got really
sick relatively young
and he was on ventilator and then he
passed away then i was like man
this is getting serious as the death
toll rises to more than 200 000 deaths
the 4.2 million indian americans that
make up the diaspora
can only help from afar due to the do
not travel advisory issued by the state
department
many of them can only wait for bad news
to reach them through a barrage of
whatsapp messages
a call or a social media post it will
affect families i
agree because the india dysphoria
is still having where a lot of people
immigrated united states but not
you know the parents are still back in
india uh they're
they're they're somebody's wife is still
back in india
so you know so so there is still that
disconnect you know on that and before
covert you know people were trying back
and forth and visiting each other but
now it's become very difficult
images of hospitals overflowing with the
sick and dying are flooding social media
as medical staff and public alike make
desperate appeals for oxygen supplies
in the uk british indian communities
took part in a 48-hour bike relay
covering the distance from london to new
delhi
in an attempt to raise money to help
with the kovit 19 situation
in india i think as british indians it's
you know it's been quite distressing for
us to see what's been going on our home
and of course we can't be there
physically in the time we're in at the
moment
and um due to that we're just doing a
little bit away from home
i guess it can't escape me that there's
quite a lot of a dire situation in india
right now
you know as an indian i've got friends
and family or in india i cannot do
anything
for them directly so you know it's an
opportunity to do something by cycling
so
certainly you know raised some good
money which i didn't expect
at a grand scheme of things you feel
very helpless and you were evaluating
and watching
uh everything by the minute and you know
you can call your parents
call your loved ones to see how they're
doing but there's only so much you can
do right now
if they get sick and if beds are not
available if the oxygen is not available
what can you do right now so that's
always on the back of your mind right
now
as life in the uk and the us edges back
to normal the unequal access to vaccines
is also becoming more evident for
indians abroad
only two percent of the people in india
have been fully vaccinated
compared with the 30 percent in the us
and 21
in the uk according to the bloomberg
vaccine tracker
we were reassured like in january
february oh coroner was always
over so people took the guards off
so that is the most frustrating thing
that after one year
you know we still have to call like all
the countries to please send aid and
everything when we were saying
we have enough that's the most
frustrating part
for the latest covet news bookmark
bloomberg.com forward slash
coronavirus maddie still ahead on quick
take the lead we'll explain why fast
food giants are
ramping up climate commitments as they
see their current supply chains
buckle under a wide range of shortages
this is quick take the lead
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
the ongoing chicken sandwich wars has
resulted in a poultry shortage here in
the u.s
at the same time poor yields on potatoes
are setting us up for a potential french
fry shortage as well both of which are
staples for consumers devoted to their
fast food chains maddie is
shaking her head there thanks to popeyes
chick-fil-a kfc and mcdonald's
chicken is now the most popular meat in
the u.s but the resultant poultry
shortage could lead to increased
consumer demand for plant-based options
and push fast food companies to
decarbonize their supply chains
artie ramachandran is director of
research and engagement at the fa irr
initiative it's an investor network
focusing on esg risks in the global food
sector
artie welcome to quick take you've done
a lot of interesting research on the
industry but i want to start with these
shortages that i mentioned
how does your group think about the
increasing frequency of certain food
shortages
and what does it say about supply chains
um thank you for having me scarlett um i
think it emphasizes a point that we've
been making for a while now which is
that um the food sector broadly but
certainly
animal protein supply chains meat and
dairy supply chains
are deeply vulnerable to climate related
disruption and so when i talk about
disruption i'm talking about
more droughts you know higher frequency
and severity of extreme weather events
and how that plays out into
into supply chains so some of the food
shortages that you're talking about
right now are linked
to global weather related events that
have played out in higher feed input
costs
in some cases they've increased the um
the the you know
the inflation uh pressures on on
livestock producers and that obviously
has wider implications for
for the entire economy so absolutely
absolutely
so i do want to get to your research now
because you've learned so much and
you've tracked how investor engagement
with six
fast food chains is leading them to
increase their climate commitments
what does that actually mean in practice
what does it look like
well i think to begin with i think we've
been really pleased to see that
some of these companies now um you know
have are you know their boards are more
engaged on the issue of climate related
risk
they now are beginning to acknowledge
that climate related risk will have an
impact on their supply chains and you
know in their annual filings and their
financial filings
um i think what's been really really
encouraging to see is that
when we started this engagement two two
years ago we had
uh maybe two commitments um two
companies with climate-related
commitments and that has now
been widened to six companies all six
companies and the engagements either
have sex commitments or
they plan to set um climate quite
ambitious climate related
uh commitments encompassing their entire
value so that's right
and these are some of the biggest chains
as well whether it's mcdonald's yum
brands chipotle domino's
and wendy's of course when you talk
about some of the
commitments that they're making they can
set aggressive targets for instance they
can undertake
risk scenario analysis these are all
easy to recommend and
relatively easy for companies to
implement as well but it doesn't
necessarily lead to desired outcomes
how do you jump over the hurdle of
getting companies to make the actual
operational changes to
create meaningful outcome well the
global
fast food sectors is a 600 billion
dollar behemoth scarlet so i don't want
to downplay the challenge and we have
extremely
complex um supply chains so it is it is
you know it is the challenge
that faces these companies is extensive
um they're going to have to implement
these targets and policies
and very opaque supply chains so it is
certainly a challenge for them
but i think you mentioned um you know
sort of diversification into plant-based
options and that does
you know present a really exciting
opportunity for companies
both from a risk perspective but also
from
a a growth perspective last year in the
us bumper's
food sales increased by something like
43 percent
year on year so that was nine times
faster than
total food sales so it really is a
fantastic opportunities
for companies to de-risk their supply
chains while jumping on the back angle
of
growth now one area that you've noticed
where the companies are falling
short is when it comes to water they
haven't really done enough to address
water scarcity issues
um as well as pollution why is this such
an in why is this such a challenge
well part of it is the scale of of meat
and dairy farming in the u.s i mean it's
extensive
um it's you know sort of quite
underregulated
um it produces tons millions of tons of
manure
um that really is applied to surrounding
farms there's extensive problem with
like water quality issues and
you know sort of has implications for
wildlife and biodiversity
um for for areas surrounding these farms
and for the communities that live around
these farms
so it is it is becoming a serious issue
and it is one that
you know we expect to see growing
regulation on um because as i said it
has been
rather under regulated but that will
change and for
investors want to start seeing companies
work with their suppliers on on
addressing water quality and water
scarcity issues because it is a key
input and it is a
risk in terms of license to operate as
well for many of these companies
so when you look at these companies and
the action that they're taking how much
of it would you say is reactive versus
proactive and when do you see that that
balance tipping to proactive in the next
couple of years i think we'd say it's
reactive
um certainly i think it's in response to
engagements like like this one um you
know encouraging companies to start
really looking at seriously at the risk
of climate change and what implications
that will have for their own business
models and product portfolios
um i think you know we are seeing um
sort of more proactive
action being taken by by companies
that are in the retail and the
manufacturing segments they've
sort of definitely ahead in the game um
and so i think the fast food sector has
a little catching up too
got it artie ramachandran of the fair
initiative joining us from london thank
you so much for staying up late and uh
giving us some of your insights really
appreciate it maddie
let's get you a look at some other
headlines making news around the world a
metro collapse in mexico city
has left at least 24 dead and more than
70 people
injured the incident marks one of the
deadliest episodes in the history of the
city subway system
the accident was caused by a beam
collapsing as the train passed over it
on monday night
mexico city's metro is one of the
busiest in the world
and in germany berlin police have
arrested a 53 year old man with alleged
ties to a neo-nazi group
the man is accused of sending almost 100
threatening letters to politicians
lawyers and journalists
the arrest comes as local officials warn
of the growing threat of violent
far-right extremism in the country last
year germany recorded a near
73 percent increase in anti-immigrant
crimes
and almost 16 percent increase in
anti-semitic crimes as well
and the g7 is considering a u.s proposal
to counter china's economic coercion
the biden administration suggested a
consultation mechanism that would
involve the g7 and others
to ensure a coordinated response to the
asian superpower
other global challenges under discussion
include myanmar russia
ukraine and a problem for a lot of
nations the spread of disinformation
for the latest news from your part of
the world go to bloomberg.com click on
the addition drop down
right next to the bloomberg masthead and
choose your region scarlett
all right coming up after the break here
in the u.s minorities many of whom were
hammered by the pandemic are now being
left behind
in recovery we found out what's driving
the growing economic divide
next this is quick take the lead
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars only from
bloomberg start exploring
to see what's moving the markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
the u.s economy is achieving a
remarkably fast recovery from the
recession
that ripped through the nation last year
the first quarter of 2021 saw the
strongest gdp growth in nearly
two decades but this expansion is
obscuring local pain
with minorities in some cities finding
themselves left behind by the overall
boom and hiring that we're seeing
take a look at this chart about the
unemployment rate that's broken down by
race by the fall the covet pandemic had
more than doubled the difference between
white and black unemployment and widened
the white versus hispanic gap in
unemployment by 2.3 percentage points
so this underscores a very uneven
recovery
how could all of this data play into
federal and monetary policy moving
forward though
joining us to discuss is one of the
reporters tracking the economic recovery
in communities across the country
olivia rockman olivia thank you for
joining us
obviously this has a huge impact on the
individual lives that we're talking
about beyond these unemployment numbers
but it also has a big impact on the
federal level can you talk about why
this matters
more broadly in the u.s yeah
fed chair jerome powell has said that
he's tracking alternative measures of
unemployment
and labor that includes the black
unemployment rate
and wage growth for low-income workers
and so when we dive down and look at
this data
on the metro level we see that you know
there really are wide differences and
that really if powell is looking at it
as he says he is affects
interest rates and affects how the fed's
going to move in the coming months
so i want to dig into a couple of
specific data points that you bring up
in your piece
starting with the unemployment gap that
we see widening and difference between
white and black americans and i know
that in your reporting you also found
that that difference is even more stark
when you look at the numbers for black
women in particular can you talk a
little bit about those numbers
yeah a lot of this comes from industry
level
situations for people of color in the
united states
as we know there's a lot of systemic
issues that mean many
black americans are in low-wage jobs so
for example
many black women work in you know
child care centers that had to close
down or in
grocery stores that haven't fared as
well and so
that's sort of why we're seeing that gap
widen now
something else we're tracking is as you
mentioned black women and that's
something that powell has talked about
as well
and for that group specifically they
tend to be in the most
front line jobs which have been hard hit
and there is one state in particular in
your data that's kind of
something we can look to as a beacon of
hope i guess you could say
in arizona the gap is quite a bit lower
can you talk about
what they're doing right and whether
that could be replicated more broadly
across the u.s
yeah in phoenix we saw that one of the
reasons the hispanic americans there
have recovered
better than other groups is because many
are employed in construction
and housing has been booming and so
that's been really helpful for
the unemployment rate for that group now
in the meantime
there's also a lot of hispanic-owned
businesses in phoenix and
there were a large number of ppp loans
that went to those individuals and so
overall that community has recovered
strongly
in terms of looking at other communities
it really is just this interesting
cultural and social
sort of set up in phoenix and so it'll
be interesting to see
kind of how things change elsewhere to
match that
so it sounds like these numbers are
really specific to some of the
industries here but i also want to talk
about this idea that
we're still not back to a pre-pandemic
normal
however the gap was always there even
before the pandemic this wasn't normal
we saw this gap based on race in
particular
what do you make of that gap
yeah we already had a 2.2 percentage
point gap between black and white
americans before the pandemic
and so you know even when we get to a
quote unquote recovery
that would still imply that we have a
gap and so it'll be super interesting to
see that once all of these pandemic
problems kind of lift off so schools
reopen
offices reopen people are vaccinated um
you know whether that gap is still 2.2
percent is it wider than that
is it narrower and maybe there are some
pandemic effects that
linger longer for you know minority
groups
i am not a math girl olivia i have to
admit to you but
uh hear me out here if you kind of is
there a way to when you're doing
these calculations to account for the
differences
in the type of industries that one
racial group may be more likely to be
part of
to really suss out how much of this is a
racial
dynamic in hiring that we're seeing
across the u.s is there a way
to kind of figure that out
mathematically
so we haven't been doing that for this
metro data specifically however
we do track the jobs report which is
coming up this friday and
we are able to break down by race and
industry
and so it is something that we're
watching as i mentioned for you know
black women
kind of looking at what industries that
they're in and how quickly they're
recovering
olivia thank you so much for joining us
we'll have to look at how all this data
changes when
unemployment benefits do expire this
september so we'll probably have you
back then olivia really
appreciate it scarlett coming up after
the break a new initiative
brewing to help victims of gun violence
we'll explain what we mean when we're
back in two
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things
everything you need to know about our
changing environment the politics of
global warming
we can and we will deal with climate
change in the fight against climate
change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
we turn now to a somber story that has
one small business trying to turn
tragedy into good in march 10 people
were killed and others injured when a
man opened fire in a boulder colorado
supermarket
the community came together but it was
another unimaginable mass shooting that
left
so many grieving one local brewery
upslope brewing company wanted to do
something to help the victims of this
tragedy
that brewery is offering up what it does
best and maybe a model for how companies
can step
in and have an impact matt cutter is the
president of upslope brewing and he
joins us now matt thank you for being
here i want to start with
this initiative tell me a little bit
about how it works and what you're doing
sure maddie so um uh when the tragedy
uh struck boulder you know you often
have those feelings that
you need to do something what can we do
how can we contribute how can we uh
help anybody who went through this
situation so
we uh we worked with our team and we
started reaching out to
local boulder county businesses which um
you know
boulder the city of all 100 000 people
maybe about a quarter million
people in baltimore county but a very
tight-knit tight-knit
business community so we started uh
getting ideas of like okay could we put
together
something that would support the
families of the victims
so we reached out to a number of
local uh craft breweries in boulder
county
uh they all immediately jumped on board
also a local canning company called
cannimel
and fortnite collective which is a brand
and marketing
uh company so we got together
and uh we came up with this idea the
colorado care cam
the concept is each of these breweries
would contribute one of the cans out of
a six pack
and we put the six packs together uh
with the branding
that fortnight collective put together
and um
uh cannibal who who uh could do the
do the cans for us and we would sell
these mixed six packs
out of each of the tap rooms of the six
boulder county breweries
and then a hundred percent of the
proceeds will go with the colorado
healing fund
wow really really amazing work that you
all are doing now of course
this is something that's plagued the
boulder area like you mentioned matt but
i'm curious
what made you decide to take action here
is there something that makes this fight
personal for you
yes so i didn't personally know
any of these victims or these families
um
it was surprising to me because it is
such a tight-knit community
um but we decided uh you know we had
some ideas of how we should react how we
should contribute
what could we do and then it was our it
was really our marketing folks that
came up with this idea um these are
these are people
prob probably these people and their
families have been
to our tap rooms in boulder county um
so it it's it's just kind of what we do
as as uh as craft breweries do
you know when there's a need you know
there's some come in the community
um we are in the communities so
we're it's just natural for us to jump
in and help where we can
i'm so glad that you bring that up matt
because i have this sense that brewery
activism is sort of its own genre i i
think back to the beginning of covid
when so many local breweries were
supplying hand sanitizer to their
communities
what do you make of this idea of this
kind of community of fellow beer
lovers sort of getting together and
really
you know rolling up their sleeves and
and working to make
the world a better place yeah i think
it's um
i think it's actually something that
comes uh very natural to us
it's it's something that's uh part of
our dna
as a craft brewery you know we support
our communities
when there are not tragedies going on um
we support local
non-profits um somebody uh
somebody has a need in the community
okay how can how can we be creative
and and help out and and when i reach
out
to uh these local boulder businesses and
uh in the breweries i mean nobody
hesitated
it was like yeah yeah of course
of course what what can we do how can we
contribute tell us what to do next
so what do you wish more broadly that
other business leaders who are listening
to this
would take away from uh kind of the
lesson that you're sharing
in the work that you're doing do you
think that other business leaders should
look at this as an example of you know
there's no act
too small that you can always do
something to help
yes absolutely we we all have ways in
which we contribute
uh with our own businesses our employees
our business partners
um i think it just takes you know uh
you know hitting the pause button a
little bit and and taking the time to
collect your thoughts
and think oh okay i think i know some
people who can help with this
and we could have this going and and we
could raise money this way
for the families of the victims and
contribute in the best way we can
maybe it's with maybe it's with their
local products maybe it's
uh by writing a check maybe it's uh some
other ways of support depending on
you know who these businesses are i mean
it could be as simple as a local florist
that could offer up
flowers to the to the families of the
victims um i
i think all can contribute matt cutter
president of upslope brewing company
really appreciate you being here to
share your work
scarlett what a heartfelt conversation
brewery activism i love that
all right let's get you to today's
movers and shakers these are the people
impacting the world of business politics
and sports
jessica alba's personal care brand the
honest company is aiming for a valuation
of more than one and a half billion
dollars in its initial public offering
the ipo could give alba who's the
co-founder a stake valued
at around 96 million dollars honest
company is classified as an emerging
growth company which means it doesn't
have to make the same kinds of
disclosures
typically required of bigger companies
when it goes public
one of soccer's most outspoken coaches
jose mourinho will take over the next
season
at as roma the soccer club's surprise
announcement today is a welcome sign for
a team that hasn't won italy's top
league
for two decades news of mourinho's
hiring sent roma stock up by as much as
26 percent
and republican congresswoman liz chaney
testing the patience of her colleagues
according to axios house minority leader
kevin mccarthy was caught on a hot mic
saying that he's lost confidence in her
it comes as top republicans turn on
chaney the gop's highest ranking woman
in congress
with at least once conservative leader
suggesting that she could be ousted from
the party
within a month and those are today's
movers and shakers
now coming up after the break remember
alamo drafthouse
it's coming back after filing for
bankruptcy we're going to speak with the
cinema chain's founder about what the
future of theaters look like
in the streaming era stay with us
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
summer movie season just around the
corner but after 2020 that changed life
as we know it
the movie industry is confronting change
and uncertainty many theater chains were
forced to shut their doors after months
of closures
some permanently in our weekly dive into
the business of entertainment we are
looking at one chain poised for a
comeback in this new landscape
alamo drafthouse cinema founder and
executive chairman tim league
joins us now from austin texas tim
welcome to quick take i know
it's been a crazy busy week for you a
bankruptcy judge approved alamo's plan
to be sold to a group that
includes you personally and lenders and
this group has agreed to forgive about
60 million dollars of debt
tell me how all this sets up alamo for
its next phase
well it's it's been certainly an
interesting year for not just us but the
whole industry
uh but we're we are turning the page so
what that does basically is we're coming
into the second half of this year
with a relatively clean balance sheet we
have new investment and
we're also seeing the industry start to
come back to life like
the every weekend is better than the
last there weren't even new movies out
this past weekend really
uh and it was a very very strong weekend
so
we see hope and optimism and honestly
opportunities so we're going to continue
our path to grow okay so i'm going to
pick up on what you just said there
because i think about 10 draft house
theaters are already open you're aiming
to get that to 30 by july
but what exactly are you showing if
there's no new films coming out and we
know the big studios are waiting until
the official start of summer to really
release their big movies
what will your theaters be showing in
the meantime
well really since the beginning uh we've
had a pretty diverse slate of films
so in in 2019 for example we played
around
2100 different movies at alamo whereas
you know the the bigger change they're
usually playing about 300 or so 400
movies
so what that means is we've built up an
audience for
uh interesting films and so about 70
percent of our business
is derived from big blockbusters about
20 comes from
more independent uh fair and then
10 comes from alternative content
whether it's rep
or sports or anything any kind of event
that's not a movie
and so in these times where that 70
percent was smaller
we leaned out and we were heavier and
heavier into classic films and
alternative content and um we're going
to continue to do
that for for the rest of the year gotcha
classic films and alternative content
you mentioned investments and how coming
out of bankruptcy will allow you to
uh make more investments we've obviously
come a long way from last march but
covid has not gone away um talk a little
bit about the spending that you'll be
doing uh when it comes to
mitigating the risk of exposure for
moviegoers will there be sitting changes
will there be changes made to your food
ordering system
yeah so we we reopened very cautiously
and
uh did so after we hit our own bar so
our our internal metric was
we're going to be safer than the
supermarket and so we took out a lot of
things and changed our model
so we shut down the box office it's
online ticketing only
we built a online ordering mechanism so
you could order in advance
so you could theoretically come to the
theater
do your temp check and do your uh check
in
and not touch another surface other than
your butt hitting the seat and then
leave and have a
really really safe experience and so
that's still currently where we are
um and my my suspicion
is you know the the vaccine rollout has
been great and
you know as we reach that point where
everybody in the united states has had
access to the vaccine
that to me triggers the point where okay
um
now everybody has the opportunity to be
vaccinated significant percentage of
folks have been
so we'll return to normal you know we're
estimating that's hopefully
in in q3 later this year and we'll be
cautious up until that point
gotcha gotcha there's always been some
speculation among industry watchers that
theaters were
are going to have to start offering more
of a premium experience uh on the other
side of this pandemic to really
entice audiences to come back even with
all the safety precautions that you just
laid out
your chain is known for its food for its
lux seating
and for the strict no phones policy
which i applaud um but that was before
the pandemic
what do you think it'll take now in
terms of offering new experiences to
keep
people coming back in on a consistent
basis
well for us that's really been our core
product right i i came into this
business as a total outsider with no
experience other than really loving
movies and
we've carried that forward now i have
you know some experience
but um you know the idea of premium
it's not always premium what we want to
do is just make sure that
every touch point we have with our
guests from from the website to entering
the door
to sitting down to the food you eat the
drinks to the quality of the
presentation like everything is
beautiful
and worth getting out of the home so
you know there's there's been a lot of
talk about about streamers and the
effect that's going to have on the
industry and
i don't i don't really see it that way i
see
we're in the out of home entertainment
business and so
we need to ensure that if you make a
decision to leave the home
that you've made the right one and
you're you're dazzled by the movies
when they're at their best so we're
gonna we're gonna keep up what we've
always done
and and we've been working in the lab
with a few few new tricks ah
okay i knew there would be some tricks
in there very quickly here tim
um when it comes to warner brothers
shaking up the industry and releasing
its movies at the same time on hbo max
and at the theaters
is that an experiment or here to stay
i think it is uh some
level of it is here to stay i think it
is an experiment i think
that when theaters are at its our
fullest capacity
that we're going to earn our spots and
there will be a
an exclusive window for almost all
movies that come through right
um but that said we've always been in
the business with folks who have done
day-to-day releases and that's more in
the independent sector
uh we've had a relationship with netflix
and we did very well with the scorsese
film and with roma
right um so we're we're open to it and
we we
we treat it all in in the vein of
partnership
i i think it'll stabilize with uh
something of a more like
what universal has the 17-day exclusive
window or something along those lines
tim leake really appreciate your time
and sharing your thoughts with us
founder and executive chairman of alamo
drafthouse cinema
maddie let's get you look at some other
top tech headlines from the day
crypto watchers saw a new trick from
dogecoin
the dog themed cryptocurrency that
started as a joke climbed as much as
50 today trading around 58 cents
and sending the value of all dogecoin to
about 75
billion dollars wow the surge also
triggered errors for crypto traders on
the robin hood app
and as a reminder all this comes just
days before dogecoin proponent and tesla
ceo elon musk is going to host
snl so we'll all be watching that on
saturday
and things are looking up for lyft the
share company released quarterly
earnings signaling brighter days ahead
lift reported lower losses than expected
73 million dollars
versus analyst estimates of 143 million
dollars
the company says that airport rides
airport rides rather were up
65 in recent weeks compared to january
and it's on track to be profitable by
the third quarter
and more bad news for cyberpunk they
can't get away from it one of its top
directors has resigned from
studio after facing allegations of
workplace bullying
conrad tamaskowitz served as a second
director on december's
negatively received cyberpunk he's
denied the bullying allegations but
apologized for quote all the bad blood i
have caused
for the latest tech news bookmark
bloomberg dot com forward slash
technology
and coming up after the break the video
game industry thrived in the
in the pandemic wow i'm struggling today
can the success continue we'll speak
with the ceo of a business providing
high performance gear for gamers about
what the future holds
stay with us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about apple's battle with the
maker of fortnite which is now entering
day two today in federal court epic
games is alleging that apple's app store
leaves users and developers
trapped in an anti-competitive
marketplace but the iphone maker is
hitting back
accusing epic of a fundamental assault
on a business model
that's helped millions of developers
here's ed ludlow with the latest
epic's attorneys spent the first day of
the trial trying to secure the moral
high ground
saying that apple had monopolistic
powers and the ios and the app store
were a walled garden where only apple
controlled the rules
epic ceo tim sweeney took the stand as
well on monday
and said that this was a lawsuit quote
entirely about apple's practices
he was talking about how the apple store
policies actually prevented epic
from being able to add features to
popular titles like
fortnite for example and he pointed out
that when it comes to
the commissions that apple charge
charges in a range of 15 to 30 percent
on each download apple is making more
profit
on those downloads than the developers
are themselves
that is something that apple's attorney
shot down saying that many other
platforms and competitors out there
charge similar commission fees they also
shot down
epics arguments about how it would be
beneficial for the consumer if there
were more competition
or if there were a change to ios rules
apple really emphasized the security
and anti-fraud protections that come
with the
app store payment system as an example
and it also pointed out
that 84 of the apps that are on the app
store
are free to download and that there is a
varying rate of commission especially
for the smaller companies
or smaller developers where apple
charges a lower rate
we expect to hear from the app store
chief phil schiller in the coming weeks
along with tim cook
the apple ceo but this has got a long
way to run and really
monday was about setting out each side's
grievances
and particular pressure points of where
they think the judge in oakland can be
convinced ed ludlow bloomberg news
san francisco
and again that was bloomberg's ed ludlow
scarlett
well the pandemic has given everyone
from casual gamers to professional
esporters
an excuse to upgrade their gear how's
that playing out for makers of that gear
andy paul ceo and president of corsair
which went public last september
joins us now andy lockdowns are easing
summer's approaching people are
traveling they're at least leaving the
house
have we reached peak gaming do you think
well far from it i think we're in the
middle of a a steady growth period
which is you know a couple of decades
long so what we've been through in the
last year is
really a period where people that were
already gaming have just learned to game
better and that's encouraged them to buy
you know some gear a lot of it from us a
lot of it from you
how dependent are you on activision and
other video game publishers posting
big sales i mean to what extent do
people buy their gear based on
new game releases or new console
releases or is it more of a steady drum
beat
it's actually a steady drum beat there's
no question that
when a game comes out like fortnight um
you know back in 2018 we saw a surge of
activity but
the activity surge tends to be in
entry-level products like gaming
headsets
most of the things that we sell are you
know
2 000 gaming pcs or components to build
them
uh and so that's not really uh affected
by you know
one game or another gotcha well you
mentioned that high price point what
about gaming on mobile devices your
competitors have released these
controller cases that give phones joy
pads and buttons
do you have any interest in exploring
this space yeah i think so
um i mean we've concentrated on the high
end so far
on pc gaming and recently about a year
ago we bought
a um a company called scuf gaming that
makes very high performance
uh console controllers and i think it's
quite likely that we'll move into the
mobile space but you know it's a much
lower price and
uh less populated uh area what about
content i
and i asked because microsoft was in
talks before it abandoned it to buy
discord
um how does social media platform fit in
with the rest of your business
well it's an integral part of it in fact
i i think of it the other way that
gaming is starting to become the
the the social platform uh if you like
of
of people hanging out there's a lot of
discussion these days of gaming being
the third
place where people hang out after work
and after their home
um and so that's really where people a
lot of young people are hanging out
in games uh just to socialize with each
other got it very quickly here someone
on twitter announced suggested that you
maybe go into a deal with uh gamestop
which is certainly in the zeitgeist
uh would that be a yay or nay uh we're
already selling in uh in gamestop our
stuff controllers
um but we have a very uh solid
distribution platform right now for all
our existing retailers and detailers so
uh yeah if gamestop wants to sell pc
gear that would be great
andy paul thank you so much founder and
ceo of corsair which makes those
gaming keyboards that my son is so fond
of
[Music]
[Music]
access the financial world on demand
[Music]
hear from leading economists
policymakers
and industry experts via live and
on-demand webinars
only from bloomberg
start exploring to see what's moving the
markets
visit bloomberg.com webinars
[Music]
our generation's biggest problem climate
change
is happening and the world's most
innovative solutions
transport industry buildings electricity
all of those things everything you need
to know about our changing environment
the politics of global warming we can
and we will deal with climate change
in the fight against climate change
bloomberg green has you covered
[Music]
coming up on quick take the lead
president biden sets a new vaccine goal
but demand is slowing in parts of the
u.s
what is the white house doing to get
more shots into arms
then the u.s economy is heating up again
as cities and states reopen
but bloomberg analysis shows minorities
are being left behind
we'll talk with a reporter shining light
on inclusive recovery in the aftermath
of covid19
and will there be enough action at the
box office to make movies into summer
blockbusters
is the world ready to head back inside
theaters
it is tuesday may 4th what did they say
maddie may the fourth be with you
be with you i'm scarlet and i'm madison
mills those stories and more coming up
on quick take the lead
[Music]
we start with the coronavirus vaccine
hesitancy in the u.s
is slowing the pace of inoculations
president biden is now trying to change
that he hopes to get 70 percent of adult
americans vaccinated
by july 4th we know that many adults
have not
been vaccinated because they have found
it too confusing or too difficult or too
inconvenient to get a shot
so for those having trouble finding a
location or making an appointment
we're going to make it easier than ever
the administration is also looking to
open up eligibility to adolescence
u.s health regulators are expected to
clear the pfizer shop for use among 12
to 15 year olds and that could happen as
early as this week
so how could that decision affect our
race to herd immunity that magical
moment when the world might feel a
little more normal
joining us to discuss this is dr
susannah hills
a pediatric airway surgeon and associate
professor
at columbia medical school doctor thank
you for being here
to start could you explain why is it
important for this group to get
vaccinated because i feel like the whole
narrative
has been that kids are fine so why is it
still
crucial to get this group of people the
shots
this is something that we really need to
be talking about
now as we're making this push to get
closer to herd immunity available